c'est un dossier aux nombreuses
conséquences diplomatiques les tensions
à propos des gisements d'hydrocarbures
en méditerranée orientale entre la grèce
et chypre d'un côté la turquie de
l'autre durant l'été ankara multiplie
les provocations dans cette zone
maritime
face à cette escalade la marge de
manoeuvre des européens est étroite et
doivent se montrer fermes face à air
doan sans pour autant compromettre le
dialogue avec les turcs
conséquence directe de ce conflit chypre
s'opposer jusque là aux sanctions contre
la biélorussie tant que les 27 ne
montraient pas davantage de soutien or
ce blocage empêcher l'unanimité pourtant
requise pour ce genre de décision ce
jeudi les membres de l'union européenne
se sont bel et bien pencher sur le
dossier en turquie oui en ce qui
concerne la turquie nous réaffirmons
avec force la solidarité avec la grèce
et avec chypre et il est très clair que
personne ne peut creuser un fossé entre
nous walchi twins et les scouts
il est bon qu'un dialogue fiable entre
la turquie et la grèce est maintenant
commencée
cependant nous déplorons qu'ankara n'ai
pas fait de geste constructif similaires
à l'égard de chitry presse nous
attendons donc de la turquie qu'elle
s'abstienne désormais de toute action
unilatérale en cas de nouvelles actions
de la part d'ankara l'union européenne
utilisera tous les instruments et
options disponibles
nous disposons d'une boîte à outils que
nous pouvons appliquer immédiatement
après plus de sept heures de discussions
passionnées le président chypriote sans
l'avoir obtenu satisfaction
bruxelles a appelé ankara à saisir cette
offre son côté le président turc s'est
contenté d'appeler au respect des droits
de son pays
pour sa part la turquie ne cherche
nullement à provoquer des conflits
détention de l'injustice ou de
l'illégalité en méditerranée nous
demandons une seule chose que l'on
montre du respect pour les droits de
notre pays ses lois et ses intérêts
c'est notre option préférée afin que les
malentendus économique et politique soit
résolue sur une base juste après le
changement de cap de chypre qui accepte
finalement de se ranger aux côtés des 26
autres pays membres lieu a donc obtenu
le feu vert pour les sanctions contre la
biélorussie via dritten 3 6 2 par la
procédure écrite nous mettrons en oeuvre
vendredi les sanctions à l'encontre de
la biélorussie et vous savez que ce qui
est sur la table est une liste d'environ
40 non à propos de monsieur lukashenko
non monsieur loukachenko ne figure pas
sur la liste actuelle mais bien sûr nous
suivrons la situation nous suivrons les
développements vous savez que nous
sommes en faveur d'un dialogue inclusif
sur la biélorussie les avoirs d'une
quarantaine de responsables biélorusses
accusé de répression contre l'opposition
ou de falsification de la dernière
élection présidentielle ont donc été
gelés ces derniers sont également
interdits d'entrée sur le territoire de
l'union européenne
dès ce vendredi